well of course there's a good chance you
turned on your AC as many areas of the
valley hit the upper 80s low 90s but for
some tenants in the valley that might
not be possible if your AC hasn't been
repaired by your landlord Victorious aha
joins us in the studio with your options
in Nevada having heat and AC are
considered essential Services
landlords you they have 48 hours to
respond to fix an issue related to that
but if they don't tenants you have
certain rights to keep in mind this
summer
on Monday 8 news now got an email from a
viewer named Sally Wesley she says her
apartment's rooftop HVAC system hasn't
been working properly but when she saw
our forecast last week she knew her
landlord needed to act quickly close to
90 Monday and Tuesday that will come
very close to records 91 and 92 degrees
they actually let us languish this
weekend with no air it was absolutely
unbearable in here when we went outside
because it was actually cooler outside
Wesley says she sent emails about this
since March and even had to come up with
her own Solutions just to keep cool so
how many fans in total did you buy just
to resolve this issue one two three four
five six seven seven fans also having to
buy a swamp cooler
all right
[Music]
after speaking to Wesley we reached out
to the property management company to
get answers for her Wesley let us know
earlier today maintenance came to fix
her AC unit but there could be so many
residents like Wesley not sure what to
do legal aid center of Nevada tells us
first things first let your landlord
know what's wrong then write them at
essential Services letter detailing the
issue that needs to be fixed if there
hasn't been a fix within 48 hours for
essential Services here's what you can
do withhold rent buy portable AC units
and deduct the cost from your rent or
terminate your lease
you can also notify code enforcement to
landlords need to keep their tenants
updated on the repairs if 48 hours isn't
enough to repair those essential
Services back to you